[Music]
they are a formidable site russia's
naval capabilities from the sea and from
the air the warships the nuclear-powered
submarines and the support they get from
above
vladimir putin signed a new maritime
doctrine today calling the usa its main
threat
and promised bigger better faster
weapons
in crimea though the home of the black
sea fleet the parade was cancelled after
what russia says was a ukrainian attack
by a small commercial drone
any parade there would have been without
its flagship vessel the moskva sunk back
in april the most significant but not
the only one lost so far the loss of the
moskva warship was a huge blow for
russia's black sea fleet but what they
have been extremely effective at doing
over these past five months is putting
an economic stranglehold on ukraine a
blockade on all of their black seed
ports which means that the commercial
exports and imports which its economy
relies on have been absolutely brought
to a standstill and that makes it much
more difficult for ukraine to fight
today's parade a moment of national
pride
what does it mean
but not everyone is such a fan
[Music]
foreign
a lone voice in these crowds overwhelmed
by the mighty force of patriotism which
vladimir putin whips up so well
donna mcnair sky news saint petersburg
[Music]